it's time to say goodbye to grand
gestures now it's fun the grandest it
gets these days is swiping right instead
of left as your local hopeless romantic
and sad to report romance is dead okay
I'm gonna kill you call what why because
your love life is boring it's not that
boring you read a sex poem with no sex
I do stuff make a column was born I have
made sixty seven thousand dollars and
gifts by a prostitute
no the gold digger may be the sugar baby
so are you gonna get in he's into
arrangements I could say something
please don't you don't have to do
anything you don't want to do I'd like
to see you again
you gonna date this guy no buzzer sounds
ha it's not hot hot you staring for
gonzo journalism the writer has to
become the story being solicited is just
the first part what happens afterwards
that story there's something about him
that I can uh put my finger on so what
the hell
wealthy older people supporting
struggling younger ones is nothing
revolutionary
maybe relationships aren't supposed to
be for love a for survival why don't you
have a girlfriend
oh I spend my time texting or fighting a
mutually beneficial relationship I was a
sugar baby
is dragging in all the hits I loved you
lost : I don't write a column okay my
column isn't harmless white you're not a
hooker
I can't do this right now how this works
I don't know what being a hooker feels
like whenever you feel stressed like
this oh journalism works is you follow
the story got your feelings you okay
this would be the moment where it would
seem all hope is lost but this is an
Iran home from the 90s
[Music]
[Applause]
this is my story
got bored but I got organelles bacon so
I sprinkled in a bunch of Molly no are
you are you okay
you